good evening the five extraordinary
artists nominated for Best Actress
delivered performances with complexity
and with depth they brought to life a
divorced bound woman who finds
unexpected passion with a shopgirl a
young mother who with her son escapes
captivity and adjust to the world
outside a struggling single mother an
inventor who builds a business empire a
woman whose marriage is tested by the
revelation of a decades-old secret and a
young Irish immigrant torn between two
countries and two separate lives here
are the nominees for performance by an
actress in a leading role Cate Blanchett
Carol Larson Jennifer Lawrence joy
Charlotte 145 years
Sasha Riley
and the Oscar goes to free Lawson
this is the first Oscar nomination for
brie Larson
Wow I thank you thank you first to the
Academy I want to start big because the
thing that I love about moviemaking is
how many people it takes to make it so I
want to start first with a Telluride
Film Festival the Toronto Film Festival
who gave us a chance who gave us a
platform first I'd like to thank a 20-4
for taking us movie into their hands and
sharing it with the world I'd like to
thank our director lenny abrahamson who
is absolutely incredible and the donahue
who created this world Jacob Tremblay my
my partner through this in every way
possible my real partner Alex Greenwald
I love you the whole thing to my parents
my agent my manager Christy odo and
Woodward Lindsay gallon the rest of my
team my friends my family thank you to
everyone who participated in room thank
you to all of you who saw it thank you
to the fans thank you to the moviegoers
thank you for going to the theater and
seeing our films I appreciate it thank
you